[MUSIC PLAYING]
BALA KASIVISWANATHAN:
Hello, everyone.
Good afternoon.
My name is Bala.
We're going to talk about
Apigee and the product roadmap,
but before I get
into that, I just
want to give you a
sense in terms of what
we will be covering today.
First and foremost, we'll
go through a section,
we'll talk about how
Apigee helps customers.
Then, since we are a recent
acquisition, and some of you
are going to be Apigee
customers, some of you
GCB customers, we'll
talk about the synergies
of Apigee and Google Cloud.
And then we'll get
into the actual details
of some of the roadmap
themes and focus areas.
So before we get into the
actual roadmap presentation,
the first thing I want
to start with is APIs.
We, as a company,
Apigee existed before we
got acquired by Google for
the sole purpose of helping
customers deliver great
APIs to their developers
and manage them in a good way.
So why is that important?
If you think about it,
APIs are everywhere.
So the way I think about this is
that if the code is the brain,
and all the technical
infrastructure we see
is the muscle, APIs
are kind of the air
that technology breathes, right?
It's everywhere.
And we have dealt with
a lot of customers
who have a significant
volume of APIs,
and how we help manage that.
But when we joined Google,
we almost saw a factor of 10
of what that happens
within Google,
and it gave us a lot more
excitement and capabilities
for thinking about, what else
could we do for our customers.
So that's the context in
terms of why Apigee exists
and what's the kind of
problem we are trying
to solve for customers,
in this world where
APIs are everywhere.
Now, before we get into
the actual roadmap,
so lets start with, where does
Apigee actually help customers?
Now, again, we're going to
talk about some roadmap items,
and I'm obliged to tell you
that these are our best plans.
That are no hard
time commitments here
which we can adhere to.
We'll do our best to deliver
some of these features
through 2017.
So take them all with that
context as we go through.
So first things first, we
see a lot of customers,
as you heard in the
keynote from Eric Schmidt,
that people are
currently in a place,
and they need to go to cloud.
And as they're
trying to do that,
they go through what at least
a lot of analysts and we
call as two-speed IT.
There are systems that exist
today in the enterprise, some
on premises, some in
the cloud, and they
are functioning
very well, and there
are some challenges with them.
But what's happening is,
on the consumer side,
you already have customers
who want to go faster.
They want new
mobile experiences.
They want better
retail experiences.
They want a better
web experience.
They want better partner
integrations with respect
to your businesses.
And when you want
to deliver those,
then you get into
a lot of problems,
because you deal with a lot of
issues with the APIs you have.
And this could be the
lack of visibility.
Most importantly, as you
heard in the keynotes,
security becomes a big thing.
The speed at which you can
deliver these things, that
becomes a big issue.
Then when it comes to developers
who are really trying to use
your API-- so that's internal
developers or external
developers--
the challenge
becomes the ability
to onboard them and have
them self-serve themselves
to understanding what
the APIs and what they
can build using those APIs.
The last, but not
the least, is what
I love to call a
successful catastrophe.
What I mean by that
is that you did not
expect things to be popular.
And you heard the
example of Pokemon.
So that's a good
example of what happens
when somebody plans, they
do their best estimates,
and suddenly, things go
through the roof in a good way,
and then you need to
deal with that, right?
So all those traits
apply very much to APIs.
So when you think about
all these problems,
whether its visibility,
whether its agility,
whether it's security,
or the fact that you have
a happy coincidence of fantastic
success, and you need to scale,
all these problems are where
we want to help our customers.
So where do we actually fit
in the enterprise stack,
so to speak?
Because a lot of
you have a notion
of what is in your
organizations,
what are you doing with
different systems today.
So we are essentially
the layer which we want
to call system of engagement.
And this essentially gives
you a very intelligent way
to manage these APIs and address
those problems we talked about,
which is, how do you
help secure your APIs,
how do you scale your APIs,
how do you have analytics
around your APIs,
and how do you do
developer management, and
last but not the least,
how do you have some persistent
layer in case you want to build
an application quickly and take
advantage of the facilities
we provide you?
So this is the
context in which we
are able to help our customers.
Now, if you take it
one more level deeper,
in terms of what exactly
does the product do,
we begin with the notion
that we have a developer,
and that's the developer
we are trying to sow.
And this is something we
call a digital value chain.
We've been talking to customers
about this for the last five
years, and it resonates
very, very well,
because at the end of
the day, the consumer who
is using an app does not know,
does not care, and does not
need to know about APIs.
When they want to click a
button on your application
on your mobile phone, or click
a button on your website,
it should work,
it should perform,
and that's all they care about.
The developer who is really
creating this application also
does not care what your
back-end systems are--
how old they are, how new
they are, are they scalable,
are they reliable,
are they redundant?
They shouldn't care
about all of that stuff.
They have an API,
and they are going
to create an application
using that API,
and it should perform
what that API says.
The contract between the
API team and the developer
is the API, and
that's very important,
because the developer does
not need to know the team--
does not need to
know the nuances
of the system behind it,
which is power the API.
All they care about
is the contract.
If you tell me this is
the version 1 of API,
and this is what it's supposed
to do, and it's documented,
I expect it to
behave that way, I
expect it to perform that
way, I expect a certain SLA
for that API.
And as long as you do
that, my application
is going to perform
beautifully and deliver
the right experience
for my customers, which
could be your customers.
The API team, on the other
side, is also thinking about,
how do I do all this when
I have a variety of systems
in my infrastructure?
Some of them are really modern,
containerized applications--
they can scale beautifully,
They are elastic--
whereas some of the systems are
fairly brittle, they're old,
but they function for
a specific reason.
You need to figure out how
to kind of abstract all that
and provide a clean API for
the consumer of that API.
So that's effectively the story
this digital value chain is
trying to tell you, is that
the contract is the API,
and the people you really
care about are the developers.
Again, this could be
internal developers who
don't need to talk to teams,
or know who is actually
managing the API or
managing the system,
or external developers
or partners who
could be using that API to
deliver some great value
for you and your customers.
The API team is also
thinking about this as a way
to develop APIs, or finesse or
enrich APIs which you already
might have.
And they are also
developers in our eyes,
and our product is also
supposed to help them and solve
the problems for them.
So those are the
two constituents
we try to solve for.
And before I get into
any more detail on this,
just a show of hands, how
many of you here have heard,
used, or are using
Apigee right now?
OK, about a 1/3 crowd here, OK.
So now, let me get into
what exactly is the product.
The product we have
is called Apigee Edge.
And the way you want
to think about this
is a very important runtime
aspect of the product, which
is the bottom half of
the slide, and there,
we care a lot
about how do you do
the right security,
right transformation,
the right mediation for whatever
you need to make your APIs
work extremely well.
That's job number one.
Along with that, we
have a set of services
which really make life
easy for the developer who
is using the API, and
also the team which
is producing the API.
And they include things like
delivering an awesome analytics
experience, so that you
can look at all the data
and make decisions around,
is my API performing well?
Does the API have the right SLA?
And is it being accessed
by different teams
in different parts of the world?
And all those kind
of data points
can be easily
visualized and seen
in the analytics dashboard.
It also allows you to very
easily publish documentation
on a developer portal and
let your developers come
to the portal and say, I want
to learn more about APIs.
It could be a store's
API, if you're a retailer,
or it could be a user
information, or a customer
information, or
account information
if you're in, say,
financial services.
So I come to the
developer portal,
and I want to learn
about a certain API,
so I should be able to
go, search for that API,
look at the documentation,
and understand
what exactly does the API do,
and more importantly, what
are the steps I need
to take to consume
that API in a secure and
authenticated fashion?
And there, again, you
want the developer
to be very empowered to go
there and learn about that API
themselves.
And then he or she
can go and figure out
what they want to build.
What are the new
experiences they
can think about or imagine?
And then ask for permission and
get some access to that API.
You want to make this process
as frictionless as possible,
and that's the goal of providing
your tool set like this.
Number three is, we've seen
many customers have large
set of different
organizational boundaries
within their company, right?
You have a department
A, department B,
and sometimes they don't
talk to each other.
And this is one way to make them
talk to each other in a very
simple, technological way.
And when you do
that, you always also
have to think about all
the other obligations
the organization has.
Sometimes they could be
a regulated industry,
and I've talked to a lot of
financial services customer,
and they go that my credit card
team cannot talk to my banking
team, or my banking team
cannot talk to this other team.
When they say it,
what they mean is,
the data has to be isolated, and
people who are working on those
APIs, and the data
behind those APIs,
have to be very well protected
in terms of who accesses it
and who cannot access it, right?
So those are the kind
of things we can again
do with management
services, where
you can have a logical
separation within the product
we have.
So you can create teams
which operate separately.
But the beauty of this
is that you can still
expose all of that API
into the developer portal
as one consistent
kind of interface.
What I mean by that is,
if you're a company which
has developer.mycompany.com,
and if I'm a developer who
wants to come and
explore the APIs,
I actually do not care that
you have 15 departments
in your organization.
I just want to know, what
are the things you have
available for me as APIs, where
we could collaborate and create
something interesting for our
customers, which can benefit me
as a business and
you as a business?
That's what I'm after.
So showing your organizational
boundaries on a developer
portal doesn't serve
any good, but it's
something very
important when it comes
to providing the APIs
within your organization,
because you want to be
very careful about whatever
your obligations
are when it comes
to regulatory or
compliance reasons.
So that's the core
of the product,
in terms of the
high-level functionality.
But the most important thing
I want you to take away
from this particular product is
not only the governance piece
and the organizational
permission and capability
which I described, but the fact
that we have built this product
to be truly multi-tenant,
and it's available today
for you as a SAS product.
However, we've also
taken the extra step
to make sure that we are able
to ship the same stack to you,
and deliver to you on
premises, should you
choose to run it on premises.
And the reason we
did this was we'd,
again, go back to a
lot of these industries
where it's extremely regulated.
And they're still figuring
a way to move to the cloud,
and we don't want
them to lose out
on the benefits of an
API-first strategy,
and how they manage and deliver
these APIs in a good way
to their own internal developers
or external developers.
The third piece is
that we also understand
that the customers who are
actually doing hybrid, which
is they do want to run some on
the actual runtime features,
which are at the bottom
of the slide, on premises,
but the rest of the
stuff, they don't want
to actually manage and operate.
And they want to let Apigee
kind of deal with that.
And that's, again, the hybrid
approach that we have today.
We built this product
about 4 and 1/2 years ago,
and we have always stuck
to very much a cloud
native kind of principle.
It's a distributed
computing model.
We have used a lot of
open-source technology
in terms of having the best
persistence layer, the data
layer, or the runtime
layer components.
And we can scale
effectively very,
very well for any customer
who chooses to use it.
And of course, we also care
a lot about compliance.
So we do have HIPAA or
[INAUDIBLE] certification,
and things like that,
for customers who
really care about that stuff.
So what has that meant for us?
What has that
meant for us is, we
have had over 350
enterprise customers
who use the product today.
Some of the marquee names you
can think about in retail,
in financial services,
in travel, hospitality,
you name a vertical,
we have customers
who are using this today.
And just last year, thanks
to the way we do our product,
we shipped over 90
features in year 2016.
But last but not the
least is that we actually
help handle, just in our
cloud, over a billion calls
a day in terms of API traffic.
So we have proven,
again and again,
the scalability of the platform
and how we can help customers.
You heard Dan talk about
Home Depot as a great example
for using GCP, and they happen
to be also an Apigee customer.
And again, so we've had
customers like them,
and others in retail, who use
us regularly for Black Friday.
And we have had a 50% jump, year
over year, from 2015 to 2016,
in the amount of
traffic we've been
able to handle for these
retailers on our product,
for Black Friday specifically.
So all these things are
the proof points for you
in terms of making
sure that A, there's
a very real need for you
to deliver quality APIs
and give them in a
very easy to consume
and in a very good contract way
to your customers, number one.
Number two, you need
a platform like this
to manage, monitor, analyze,
and deliver a great experience
to your customers.
Last but not the least,
you need something
that's to bridge and
help you get to the scale
and get to the agility
you want to have.
So that brings us to
the next thing, which
was, in November 2015 is
when Google acquired us.
So we are all part
of the Google family
now, specifically in
the Google Cloud team.
And what I want to go
through with you now
is kind of the synergies we
have as part of Google Cloud.
I just want to give you
a bit of context on that
and then get into the
actual roadmap discussion.
So when you think about the
cloud, Google Cloud itself,
there is a very
specific set of things
we are trying to help
customers, right?
We talked about the fact that
we have the infrastructure which
we've built over the years
at Google Cloud, which
is unsurpassed.
So we can actually give you the
optimization and cost benefits
like nobody else can.
We have invested in
a lot of technologies
when it comes to data
and machine learning,
again, which you can
benefit, and take your data,
and apply the right
insights to your business
based on that data.
We have provided some of the
market-leading Container Engine
technology to make
sure that you're
able to go and do what you need
to do for modern application
development.
How do you connect
different platforms
and create the right ecosystems?
That's another problem
we want to solve for you.
Last but not the least,
we want to make sure
that you have the right devices,
which make you productive
and also secure.
So how do you bring
all this together
when you have this challenge?
The challenge here is,
as you're modernizing
a lot of things in
your IT infrastructure,
you're going through
this challenge of saying,
I have all these layers,
whether it's infrastructure,
whether it's creating
platforms, or they're
building applications,
securing my devices.
But if you think
about the speed,
the speed varies
depending on where you are
and the workload you have.
So to be very
open, this slide is
very subjective to what
you're doing, right?
You could be looking at it
in terms of your private data
center for certain aspects
and certain workloads,
and you could be looking
at certain other workloads
in hybrid, certain in cloud.
And they will have a
varied speed when it comes
to what you are able to do.
And this is not very
dissimilar to what
we talked about earlier, when
it came to the two-speed IT,
right?
It's a very similar
kind of problem.
So the number-one takeaway
I hope you all have,
listening to the
sessions in the keynote
and other sessions you
do today and tomorrow,
is, we are very
committed to meeting you
where you are, and help
you grow from there.
So let's look at
what does that mean.
So first and foremost the way
we think about the problem sets
is in these five areas, right?
Infrastructure, storage,
network, something
I don't think anybody has
any more questions around.
They understand the value.
They understand the
optics around that,
and the efficiencies on
running infrastructure
at a Google Cloud scale.
The second thing,
which I think was
a lot about the keynote
today, which is about,
how do you deliver value using
the data and machine learning
capabilities?
That's, again, something
you've all heard.
The third one is getting
to be very interesting,
where you are able to build
interesting new applications,
both from an experience point
of view, and how you can scale,
and how you can have very good
containerized applications
delivered for your needs.
The connected business
platform is essentially
where we're talking
about, how do you
bring an ecosystem together?
Again, when we talk
about ecosystems,
it's the APIs powering different
things for your businesses,
and how you showcase
them in a marketplace,
whether its internal
or external,
and how you can have different
participants and consumers
in that ecosystem.
And last but not the least,
when it comes to teams, devices,
and security, we again have
a very clear way to help you,
with G suites and the mobile
and laptop devices we have.
So with all of that, this is
how the portfolio looks, right?
So when you look
at this portfolio,
obviously, you're looking
at, from an infrastructure,
storage, and
network perspective,
one of the most cost-efficient
cloud storage, networking,
and computer
infrastructure you can get.
You're looking at one of the
most advanced machine learning
[INAUDIBLE] capabilities,
which you can take advantage of
and apply for your businesses.
You're looking at the best
open-source, containerized
App Engine out there
which you can use.
And then when you look at the
connected business platform,
you're looking at how we deliver
our own APIs, as a finished
product, which you can
consume as a customer,
and also have Apigee
deliver your APIs in a very
similar fashion to what we do,
for example, like Google APIs.
And last but not
the least, having
the efficiency, and the
productivity, and security
for your knowledge
workers, with G Suite
as well as Chrome devices.
So lets go one level deeper on
this in terms of what exactly
is "meeting where
you are" means when
it comes to the connected
business platform.
We understand that a lot
of our enterprise customers
today have a lot
of infrastructure
and applications on premises,
and some in the cloud.
And what they tend to
do is, they do also
have existing legacy
integration because of the needs
they had a decade ago.
As you move forward,
you've got to figure out
how you're going to
expose all of this as APIs
and be consumable
for your developers.
That's kind of where
you're at right now.
So we want to make sure that
we are able to help you,
starting with wherever you are
in terms of your exposure layer
and integration layer, and
then take that and give you
the facilities to
deliver it as APIs.
Now, what does that do, though?
I mean, you can always
argue that I already
have an abstraction, I
have a middleware tier,
and I've invested in that.
The challenge with that is, it's
a very exposure-driven model,
and it does not take into
account the developers
who are going to consume it.
So where Apigee is really
trying to come and help
you is about helping the
consumption part of it.
The developers who are
internal, or in partners,
or external partners, who
want to develop on APIs,
that's where the consumption
is going to happen.
And if we can help you with
that, that will make sure
that you have a
lot of agility, you
can have a lot of
innovation, and you can also
have a lot of business growth,
because you're creating
that ecosystem for yourself.
And it also leads to a lot
of new business models.
So for example, one of the
favorite examples we have
as Apigee, as a
customer, Apigee customer
is, for example, Walgreens.
Walgreens, for those--
I apologize, if people
have traveled here
internationally-- is a
local pharmacy chain,
and a large
brick-and-mortar chain.
They have always had the ability
for you to upload a picture,
and then print it,
and go pick it up
in a nearby Walgreen's store.
Now, think about that.
As the entire experience
shifted for people
who stopped taking pictures
on a digital camera,
and they started taking
pictures on the phone,
that business
infrastructure still
is there but is not
being realized in terms
of a new business model.
So what did we do with them?
So we started with them, where
we experimented with something
called a photo print API.
So all it does is, it
allows you to upload
a picture from your phone
and then fire a print-out,
and figure a store near
you and pick it up, right?
Sounds simple enough,
and the good thing
is, they had already some of
the back-end systems available,
so this was possible, using
the technology we have
and the systems they had.
But that's the first part.
So you could almost say that
we took a web-based approach
with digital cameras and turned
it into an API-based approach,
for a mobile app plus the store,
thanks to this technology.
That's the starting point.
Once they got that going, the
second piece of the information
there was, If I polled
this room, how many of you
would take a picture
on your phone
with the native camera app?
OK, so this is a good
example of saying,
nobody is going to
download a Walgreens
app to take a picture, right?
So therein lies the problem.
So you're going
to take a picture
with a photo-taking
app of whatever you're
comfortable with.
And then that's what the
next step was with Walgreens.
They said, OK, how do I take
this and integrate it with
other applications, which are
photo-taking applications,
but if I let them
print onto my site--
sorry, my Walgreen's store,
that would be awesome.
So you, as a consumer,
get to take a picture
on whatever app
you want, but you
can fire a print-out
whenever you want
and pick it up in
a Walgreen's store.
Now, that's great, right?
But why should a
developer do that?
Guess what-- there are hundreds
of photo applications today
on iOS and Android,
and everybody's
trying to figure out
how to monetize that.
What did Walgreen's do?
Said, you know what?
You send a person to my
store to pick up a print-out,
we'll do a dev share.
You send me traffic,
foot traffic,
and I'll give you something
back out of the photo printing
revenue.
Great business model.
That's a new business
model, right?
And now you've innovated,
because you have hundreds
of these app developers who have
photo-taking apps, some large,
some small, some very
local in certain countries,
in specific regions
of the country--
sorry, in the world--
they all are trying to
do interesting things
with the photo-taking apps.
Walgreen's is not in the
photo-taking app business,
so they wanted to
see how best they
can take advantage of that, and
turn that into a new business
model, right?
And here's the other statistic.
When you have a customer
walk in to pick up
the printout of the
photograph, guess what happens.
They pick up something
else at the store.
So in retail, for somebody
to walk into the store,
and trying to get somebody
to come into the store
is hard enough, but
here, you have a customer
who can voluntarily come
inside, pick up the print-out,
and they take something back
and buy something in addition
to what they came for.
That is gold in retail, right?
So that's the innovation
in terms of business model.
But that's not where we stop.
Then, Walgreen's
started to think about,
what are the other things I do,
which can be done like this?
One of the things
they do is a pharmacy.
Guess what's the pain point
in pharmacy-- and especially,
if people who are in
the US who know this--
is when you have to go and
fill up your prescription again
every month, or every 30 days,
or 15 days, or whatever it is,
right?
They said, if I could automate
this process, where you could
take a picture of the
medicine you have,
and the app figures out that
you're qualified for a refill,
and you're ready for a
refill, and I'll notify you
when the refill is ready, so you
can pick it up on the way home
or on the way to the
office, life is easy, right?
So they could do
that, and now they'll
do a refill almost
every minute, right?
So that's, again,
an innovation, which
it leads to brand
loyalty, great experience,
and driven by an API technology.
The last, but not the
least, thanks to a lot
of this innovation is, now
they have a fantastic ecosystem
of partners who really
are able to deliver
different experiences and
different integrations.
So now you could go
to a Walgreens app
and ask a question
about a condition,
or research a medical issue,
and then figure out an answer.
And if you have
the medicine there,
you can see if there's
a Walgreens outlet which
can actually be
nearby you, where you
can go pick up that medicine.
So all sorts of
innovations suddenly
start to happen
with that journey.
So when I talk
about APIs, it's not
about taking your legacy
integration and exposure
and then just letting it be
through another technology
layer.
But this is really
optimized for consumption.
And the developers can be
your own internal developers,
they can be external
developers or partners.
But the impact you're
trying to drive
is all about, how do you
drive new business models
and keep innovating?
And this could mean
API monetization,
it could mean
partner ecosystems,
it could mean different
things for different customers
and businesses, but
that's the actual benefit
that you're trying to drive.
So I hope that's given
you a sense, in terms
of where we are trying to do
the whole ecosystem and business
model with a connected
business platform.
And this is, again--
this is not new
to Google, right?
So today, we have over
3 million businesses
that use our Google Maps APIs.
So we know a thing
or two about what it
means to have an awesome API.
How do you manage this at scale,
how do you build an ecosystem,
and how do you have
businesses consume those APIs
for interesting things, right?
That's something we do.
We're doing the same
thing with other things,
like Language API, or Vision
API, and things like that.
So our goal is to apply both
the learnings and the knowledge
we have at Google Cloud
and Google for running
scalable global APIs
and creating ecosystems,
and marrying that with the
technology we have with Apigee,
and also having
Orbitera there, which
is all about monetizing
and creating marketplace
for applications, all
together, to bring
the value to you in a
connected business platform.
So that's what we
are trying to do,
and that's the synergy we
bring with Apigee, Orbitera,
and Google Cloud.
So, with that context, I hope
you found it really useful,
let's switch gears and
talk about what exactly
is the Apigee roadmap, and some
of the themes and focus areas.
So there are three big
areas which we focus on.
Number one multi-cloud,
number two,
delivering awesome
APIs, and number three,
machine intelligence.
So we'll go through
each one of these.
Why is multi-cloud important?
We have talked to
a lot of customers.
At Apigee, even before we joined
Google, I would meet at least 5
to 10 customers a
week, and we have
a lot of other folks at Apigee
who meet customers daily.
The reality of the world is
a multi-cloud world, right?
People have investments
in different clouds--
sometimes its public clouds and
sometimes its private cloud,
or on-premises data centers--
but the reality, is people have
investments across the board.
And it's our job,
as a product company
who are helping customers take
that leap into the cloud world
and make the digital
transformation, to provide you
with the right tools
that's whereever you are.
So today, we see customers
not only using Google Cloud,
but we have customers who are
on premises using Pivotal Cloud
Foundry, for example, and
using other public cloud
technologies.
We also see people using
just their own data centers,
VMs, using containers, using
Kubernetes on premises--
all that stuff is
happening today.
So we have to really help
customers, whatever they are,
and that's an important,
and a very urgent need,
so that they can
move forward when it
comes to their digital journey.
So what are we doing
specifically for that?
So I showed you
the slide earlier,
where it was really about
how our product functions.
There's one difference
in this slide,
which is, we have
embarked on a very
aggressive hybrid approach.
What does that mean?
That means that our
runtime layer is something,
we're going to make sure
that it's available to you,
and you should be able to run
it wherever you want that to be.
So it could be in another public
cloud, it could be on premises,
it could be in Pivotal
Cloud Foundry--
anywhere you want
to run the runtime,
you should be able to run.
So in the future,
we envision a world
where the runtime could be,
for example, Google Endpoints.
You could have our own
gateway enterprise--
Apigee hybrid
gateway, or it could
be even some other open-source
gateway that you're running,
wherever you're running.
Our job is to be
able to give you
a clean, single pane of
management and control
across all of that, and give you
all the other abilities we just
talked about earlier
today, right?
So that's the number-one goal.
And I'm very happy to
announce that we actually
are delivering the first part
of this, in fact, in a session
one of my colleagues
is doing right now,
where we're announcing the early
access program for our Edge
Hybrid Gateway today.
And you can read about it more
on apigee.com later this week,
and we'll be opening
it up for customers
to sign up and start using it.
And the goal here is
that A, you should
be able to take
this hybrid gateway,
run wherever you
want to run this,
and it's still managed
remotely, and it does not
have the constraint of having
to always stay connected
with the management layer,
which is running in the cloud,
or it can also be
customer managed.
So everything you see on
the top half of the slide
can be either Apigee
managed or can be
managed by you as a customer.
The other important
point in the slide,
which I want to make sure that
you understand from a roadmap
perspective, is
that we also believe
that giving you a gateway,
or giving you a runtime,
to run wherever you
want, is the beginning.
Let's say you're running this
on a different public cloud
or on Google Cloud.
The next thing you
would want to do
is make sure that the runtime is
able to take advantage of some
of the services on that cloud.
So that's the other piece
we're going to invest in,
which is, give you the
native integrations out
of this runtime,
wherever you need them.
So for example, if you
had to do something
like invoke a Google
function from the gateway,
we should make it
very easy for you
to do from our runtime layer.
So we already have
a runtime layer
which is very
sophisticated than anything
in the marketplace,
because we let you have--
run Node code in it.
You can actually do
service call-outs
using Java, Python,
or JavaScript.
All of that
functionality is awesome,
but when you're running
that particular runtime
layer in a cloud, you
should be able to access
all the functions of that
particular cloud very easily
and should be able
to integrate that.
So that's the other
important aspect
of how we're thinking about
this whole hybrid approach.
So again, to summarize, the key
takeaway from this slide is, A,
we are committed as
Apigee to multi-cloud.
Number two, our big
bet is around hybrid,
so you should be able to run
our runtime layer wherever
you want to run this.
And number three, it
should provide you
all kinds of native
integration capabilities
over a period of time,
so that depending
on the cloud you're using,
you should take advantage
of that native facility, OK?
That's multi-cloud.
Let's look at APIs.
So when I think
about APIs, there
are two things which we need
to really, really make sure
that happens.
Every CIO, every
product executive,
every API program owner I
talk to, talks about security.
It's not a cloud topic, it's
also an API platform topic.
At the end of the
day, when you are
trying to expose your APIs to
the world or to your partners,
security is key.
So we will continue to innovate
and deliver the best security
features you can
have when it comes
to the runtime
and managing APIs.
So we just went live last
week with the SAML support
and for our core offering.
That means you should be
able to use any SAML provider
for authenticating both our
management layer as well
as the runtime layer.
That gives you a
lot of flexibility
in terms of controls, in
terms of who authenticate--
who is able to access and
authenticate themselves
in using APIs.
We are also making sure
that it's very easy for you
to manage certificates when
it comes to two-way TLS
connections or
anything else, again,
giving you the ability to watch
for when they're expiring,
renewing them, making sure the
API SLAs are not going down
because of those kind of issues.
There are other two big themes
which I want to hit upon here.
One is, we do want to make sure
that as organizations adopt
the API-first approach,
what we are seeing
is a larger pool
of folks who are
trying to help drive the overall
digital journey in the company.
And that brings in a
lot of security issue,
which-- it's with
respect to people
and what they can access.
So we're investing
specific set of energy
around making sure that we
don't create a friction,
because one of the
things we want to avoid
is a very strong, very
top-down governance
model, because what happens
with that is, it takes away
the speed and the agility
and the interations
you need in an API program.
So instead, what
we're going to do
is provide you very easy ways
to either live off your existing
authorization models,
and create ad hoc teams
and permissions
services on top of it,
or give you a very
lightweight model
to create the
right set of folks,
and the right set of permissions
for what they need to do,
on top of a platform.
The essence here is to give
you visibility, control,
but at speed and scale.
That's the goal out
here, not to give you
a very stoic, straitjacketed
way to do something in terms
of actual governance models.
Last but not the least,
we also understand
that there are a lot of
existing ways in which you
can manage keys.
So it could be for
rotations, could
be for encryption,
and things like that,
and you have existing
policies, and you may
have existing infrastructure.
And one of the things
we're going to do
is make sure that we invest
enough to integrate with those
so you don't have
to reinvent them,
because you may have gone
through a lot of due diligence
in making sure that they are
the ones which are helping you
with respect to compliance, and
some sort of regulatory burden,
right?
So we want to make
sure that's there.
So this is security.
So for everything
we do in security,
which is to make sure
that your APIs are safe
and your obligations around
compliance are there.
We also want to
make sure that we
have a fantastic,
delightful user of the API
and the product we have so
that you can do your best
work with our product.
So first thing
we're doing there is
that we're moving from our
classic UI, which kind of is
what we've been having
for about 3 and 1/2,
4 years now, to something
we just launched
late last year, towards
the end of the year, which
is this kind of an experience.
So it's not just a cleaner
modern design in terms of UI,
but it's very focused around
what you want to get done
and how fast you want
to get things done.
There are a few things we want
to do very much out of this,
which is, number one is, we
want to make sure that we make
the OpenAPI Spec a first-class
citizen within our UI
and our product.
And for those who are already
familiar with OpenAPI Spec,
you know the importance
of this open standard,
that you can describe and
have the right kind of API
specifications.
You can collaborate on them.
And so we provide a very
simple in-line [INAUDIBLE]
were you can actually
collaborate and create
the specifications.
But we don't stop there.
We let you create the
right API proxies right out
of those specifications
so that you
can go faster in terms of what
do you want to do with it.
You can even mock an API, and
have your developer consume
that API, and build
an application
without actually really
having a back-end system.
Those are the kind of things
you could do with what
we have in our product.
The other thing you do is, once
you have an API proxy or API,
you should be able
to think about,
how do you want to package it
for the consumers of this API?
As I mentioned before, this is
all about the consumption, not
about the exposure.
So we do that as well.
And that means you can package
up, create the right products,
and then publish them in a
portal in a very easy way.
So again, in this particular
exercise, what we have done is,
we've let you do a very, very
simple, easy portal, which
is configurable, which you
can go and publish everything
in terms of documentation
and your products,
and get your dev portal--
developer portal ready
in under 10 minutes.
And that's the goal we have.
And last but not
the least, we want
to make sure that
everything else you do here
is easy, self-serve, and you
are able to actually take
advantage of the
steps we provide you,
and you can explore
the right way.
So we made sure that this
particular experience
is very, very intuitive, and
it's very helpful for you
to be more productive.
So in terms of the actual focus,
in terms of future themes,
we continue to do
OpenAPI support.
And in fact, there is a current
draft of OpenAPI Spec 3.0,
so as it gets ratified,
we want to make sure
that we are on top of
that and support you
in having that support.
We continue to
improve and innovate
on our next-gen
developer portal,
and giving you more
features, and making it
configurable, yet powerful.
And this also means we
give you two options.
We have a very
strong customer base,
which uses our Drupal
Developer Portal, which
is extremely flexible,
very highly customizable,
and takes advantage
of a large community
of open-source development
around the Drupal technology.
But we're also going
to give you something
which is a very simple, hosted,
configurable portal, which
you can go and start
up very easily.
As people mature in
their API journey,
we are also seeing
that a lot of folks
want to actually start
thinking about monetization.
So one of the things
you'll see is,
while we have a fantastic
monetization product,
we built it for
large customers who
have complex business models.
We are going to
invest in making sure
that you have very easy and--
easy ways to monetize the
APIs, and probably very simple
ways to try what you can in the
marketplace and keep adjusting,
so you can find
out what's the best
way to go and create
those new business
models which you want to do.
Last but not the
least, any API program,
for it to be successful,
needs to have a good community
participation.
And this community could be
all your internal developers,
and it could be all the
developers in your partner,
or a broader ecosystem.
We want to make sure that
we give you the right tools
to bring in that
community, or you
to get access to that community,
as part of the product itself.
So that's kind of
the other aspect.
So as we look at all of these,
the key takeaway for-- sorry,
going back--
the key takeaway for APIs
is, we want to make sure
that we deliver secure APIs.
And we make sure that the APIs
are available for consumption
in a easy way.
And that's kind of our
goal with the APIs.
Let's go to the third and--
interesting aspect of
machine intelligence.
I'm sure you're hearing
everything from, you know,
self-driving cars to
artificial intelligence.
All of this stuff is exciting.
It's very, very exciting.
And we are really hoping that
as a Google Cloud customer,
you're able to take
advantage of all the big data
and the machine
learning APIs we have
and build something awesome,
like you heard in the keynote.
While we do that, we, as
Apigee, are also looking at this
and going, what is the stuff
we can do in our product, which
allows us to make the
product shine better,
thanks to these technologies?
And that's in a very
important initiative for us.
So I'm going to walk you
through some examples in terms
of what we're
trying to do when it
comes to machine intelligence.
The first thing we realized
is that once you have APIs,
the scale at which APIs
can get abused or attacked
is significantly different than
what you've seen before, right?
Because there will be
somebody who leaks an API key,
and you'll have
sophisticated programs.
They will come at that API
from different IP addresses,
at different times,
at different speeds,
in terms of requests per second.
So a simple rule-based
approach just doesn't work.
So all our APIs, you
could do something like
put a spike [INAUDIBLE] policy.
Like, you can say, OK, more
than 1,000 requests per second?
Just shut down-- don't respond.
But the advantage these bots
have is, they can learn.
They can go out and you at
1,000 requests per second,
and once they know
you're getting blocked,
they can keep coming
at you at 999, right?
And then you say, no, I'll
figure out the IP addresses.
But if it's a mobile client
API, but it's coming from--
in a public cloud
IP address, maybe I
can shut it down immediately.
They can spawn IP addresses.
So you can keep chasing
these things, right?
So the goal here
is to provide you
with tools which are able to
prevent those bot attacks,
and also make sure that you're
able to detect them correctly,
and then make sure that you're
able to prevent those attacks
from taking your systems down.
And how do we do that?
And this is where we
are taking advantage
of the machine learning
capabilities at Google
and applying them to a very
specific context here, which
is the APIs, right?
So here, we would look at
patterns-- patterns meaning,
is there a slow-burn call?
Where is it coming from?
Is it from multiple places?
Is it for a specific
resource on that API?
What times do it come--
do they come at?
All these things can be done,
and learned continuously,
so that we can give
you the right warning,
saying, hey, these API calls
looks like bot attacks,
so you need to do something,
and give you the right tools
to do it.
Or in some cases, we actually
know it's a bot attack,
and we can do some preemptive
action on your behalf.
And that's something
which can only be done
at scale with machine learning.
There's no other way to do
this because of the volume--
sheer volume and
magnitude of these kind
of attacks that can happen.
The second one is
about user engagement.
A lot of people use APIs
for delivering experiences
on mobile apps or web apps.
And the good news
is that you can
do some fantastic personalized
experiences to users.
The bad news is, if you don't
keep learning and changing,
you're going to deliver some
bad experience pretty soon,
because it's not, again,
a rule-based approach.
You got to look at
different factors
and deliver the
right kind of value.
And when you can
inject something
in that API to change the
experience for that customer
on the mobile app, and
deliver a very specific user
engagement or personalization,
it takes it to a new level.
So again, that's an area where
we want to invest and give you
the right tool sets, so you
can configure and attach
some models so that
you can say, here's
how I want the app to behave
if these are the things you
notice, and have that
model learn continuously,
and improve the experience
you deliver to your customers.
The last one is an
example of operations.
What do I mean by operations?
So there are a couple
of examples, right?
So you're creating
an API proxy, and you
happen to create one for,
let's say, user account.
So when it comes
to user account,
we may have seen hundreds
of user account APIs
across our customers,
and we would probably
also know what are the typical
traits of a user account?
What are the logging
patterns of a user account?
What is the traffic like?
Is it a time and date--
sorry, a frequency in
which they get used?
Or in terms of, do they have
to have some security policy,
because people typically try
to attack that, from a bot
perspective, because
they're trying
to get into an account
with brute force.
So there are a lot of
things we can actually
glean from all the
patterns we watch,
across a set of
typically known APIs--
could be slash accounts,
could be slash login.
How can we help
you say that when
you're creating a slash login
API for the first time using
our product?
We say, based on all
the customers we know,
we highly recommend
that you have
these two policies for
security with the login API.
That would be awesome.
In fact, even better would
be, as we learn more,
we actually prompt you, even
after the API is in production,
to say, hey, we
notice your login
API has been running for three
months, and blah, blah, blah.
We highly recommend, based
on some of the new threats
we've seen, you add this
additional policy to your API.
That is something we can do
for you, both from a security
perspective and making
your operational nightmare
a little bit easier, right?
The second one
could be rollouts.
We released about
every two weeks,
and we've gotten into this
blue-green model of deployments
so that we know,
when all our customer
API traffic is coming
in, we can start
with the percentage of traffic
switched to a new release,
watch it, look at the data,
look at the error rates,
and keep increasing the
percentage for the new release
before we switch over 100%.
How would we be able to give
that kind of information
to you for your own APIs?
Can we look at patterns of, when
you switch from a V1 to V2 API,
could we give you some
knowledge and say,
looks like your error rates
are way beyond the threshold.
We suggest to roll
back immediately.
Or you're looking really
good, so you should accelerate
the release cycle right now.
What are the kind of things
we can automate for you?
Is there things we can do where
we look at certain error rates
and automatically tell
you or your ops person
to do some changes to
your back-end systems?
Those are the kind of things
we can automate, again,
by learning continuously
and applying some patterns
and algos to it.
So again, this is
extremely useful
when the volumes are at
a different scale, right?
And we believe the billion
calls a day we're processing
is going to be nothing
very, very soon.
And the data we see
across our customers
is that everybody is growing
in terms of their API calls,
because everybody is trying
to take an API-first approach.
When you have that
kind of a scale,
there is nothing that
is going to help better
than having something
like a machine
learning technology which
applies in the API context.
So that's kind of
the third big market.
So in summary,
the three bit bets
are multi-cloud, delivering
great APIs, and machine
intelligence.
And what the
takeaway would be is
in terms of making
sure that it's
an API platform that
will be available to you
where you want it.
We want to deliver you the most
secure and easy-to-use APIs
using our technology.
And number three, we want to
present to you, in our product,
intelligence as an
ingredient so that you
don't have to do the hard work.
We do everything
behind the scenes,
thanks to all the
power of Google Cloud,
and deliver intelligent
features for you in the product.
So those are the three
big themes we have.
And we are very, very excited
to be part of Google Cloud
and Google, and
also look forward
to delivering some of
these amazing features.
And hopefully, some of
you who are our customers
will be taking advantage of
this through our early adopter
program.
And those who are
not yet customers,
I hope we have your trust,
and we'll get you as customers
and get into a
great partnership.
So with that, I want to
thank you for taking the time
and attending this session.
And I'll be around
in case anybody
wants any questions answered.
I'll be more than
happy to take them.
Thank you again.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]